mais là messieurs bonjour
bienvenue à cette émission spéciale de
radio canada international consacré au
7e salon de l'immigration l'intégration
au québec à du très beau monde autour de
moi on va aborder plusieurs sujets
notamment les questions d'intégration
des nouveaux arrivants l'immigration en
région les questions telles que le
regroupement familial et j'en passe tout
ce que je vous présente mes invités qui
sont très nombreux à façon pour
l'instant sept autour de moi mais y en a
d'autres qui vont s'ajouter madame line
lagacé qui est la vice-présidente
croissance des entreprises et
prospection des investissements
étrangers à québec international bonjour
nous avons monsieur ouhadi karam qui est
lui le chef du pôle employabilité la
maison née à montréal aussi bonjour
monsieur karam ou bonjour et nous avons
madame melissa m mélissa portland doit
se dire avocate au cabinet use l'anglais
qui est une cape pour expertise entre
autres choses le regroupement familial
bonjour mélissa et nous avons à ma
droite à gauche plutôt nous avons
monsieur rudy carlier qui est conseiller
en partenariats entreprises à louer des
hirondelles bonjour ce quartier une
bonjour nous avons un petit monsieur
carrier sandrine théâtre consultante et
formatrice à la source humaine bonjour
d'achat et puis à côté de karine nous
avons
nous avons appris le sens d'un dis-je
nous avons karine jolie carnon
saccharine metz plutôt marie soler bande
qui est conseillère établissements en
région a promis qu' une oasis à montréal
et s'intéresse entre autres choses à
l'immigration et jean bonjour bonjour
bon alors pour mettre la table sur
l'homme nos sujets on va peut-être
essayer de dire un petit mot sur ce que
vous faites ou ce que vous entreprise ou
votre goût tout organisme ou fonds pour
pouvoir discuter de façon plus claire
par la suite
d'abord va commencer avec vous madame
magazine ckoi québec international
c'est la chance de développement
économique la grande région de la ville
de québec et il faut comprendre pourquoi
on s'intéresse à l'immigration c'est que
l'enjeu de la disponibilité de main
d'oeuvre et l'enjeu premier de notre
région depuis une dizaine d'années
environ donc on travaille ardemment à
essayer d'attirer des immigrants et bien
sûr les intégrer et les redire chimie
très bien et vous monsieur wadi des
karam voir la maison et qu'est ce que
vous faites donc la maisonnée c'est un
organisme spécialisé dans l'accueil
l'installation les services sociaux et
les services de placement l'emploi pour
les immigrants en général on a une
trentaine de services sous le même toit
tous les services sont gratuits et
majoritairement ce sont des services
gouvernementaux donc avec emploi québec
le 1016 de l'immigration la ville de
montréal
les commissions scolaires etc on reçoit
chaque année à peu près dans les dix
mille clients
donc quand les dirigent vers les
différents services
selon leurs besoins on a aussi le volet
de cette vie spécialisée pour les gens
diplômés supérieurs dans les
technologies de pointe des technologies
avancées et même émergents ça c'est
majoritairement nos services alors une
des composante importante de
l'immigration c'est le regroupement
familial et là c'est l'une de vos
expertises mélissa pots de vin et oui en
fait donc je suis avocate
alors je pratique au cabinet de m
l'anglais donc nous sommes spécialisés
ont fait en immigration
on pratique tout ce qui est en résidence
temporaire résidence permanente et même
les demandes et citoyenneté donc on est
notre domaine de troyes nat expertise en
immigration et bailly mais oui
aujourd'hui plus particulièrement et je
peux discuter avec vous du regroupement
familial entre autres alors vous en
donner quelques détails là dessus je
n'ai pas encore pu aller pas présenté et
c'est pour ça on oublie juste à côté de
moi delphine folié qui est la directrice
d'immigrants québec
alors si on ici aujourd'hui c'est un peu
grâce à delphine et à son organisation
alors le qui compare des migrants québec
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas votre
organisme qui êtes vous au fait
rémy grand québec c'est un c'est le
premier média d'information sur
l'immigration au québec on offre
vraiment énormément de ressources
notamment sur notre site internet
migrants quebec.com pour me dire bien
préparé son départ réussir son arrivée
ici lorsqu'on arrive au québec
et puis on organise une série aussi
d'événements dont le salon de
l'immigration et de l'intégration au
québec qui en est à sa septième édition
cette année qui est no probablement
d'autres événements majeurs où on
organise aussi tout au long de l'année
des réseautage de bienvenue aux nouveaux
arrivants
et puis on
on publie une collection de guides qui
permettent aux nouveaux arrivants et aux
futurs immigrants de mieux se renseigner
sur comment immigré au québec
travaillent au québec étudie au québec
vivre à montréal vivre à québec et ses
environs vient d'en parler avait quand
même des gars c'est à vous de vous les
préparez déjà amam en avant avant qu'il
soit là mais je pense que une
immigration ça se prépare bien souvent
des années en amont c'est parfois
quelque chose qui est moins connu mais
évidemment il faut informer les
personnes avant qu'elles arrivent ici au
québec
d'accord il monsieur clavier vous alors
qu'est ce que vous vous faites à
l'hirondelle donc l'hirondelle dans un
organisme d'accueil d'intégration pour
la clientèle immigrante comme un petit
peu la maisonnée nous voulons mais c'est
sûr que nous notre mission principale
parce qu'on fait comme la plupart des
autres organismes on va s'occuper de
leur accueil de réinstallation leurs
besoins en démarche de recherche
d'emploi mais on veut surtout se
positionner comme une passerelle entre
le marché caché et le profil ignorer
justement c'est à dire les relations
avec le milieu professionnel avec le
milieu des entreprises pour répondre
faire face aux besoins de la main
d'oeuvre de ces entreprises puisque on
parle beaucoup du plein emploi c'est sûr
et certain que nous on est un acteur
important à ce niveau là dans nos
relations d'affaires professionnels avec
le milieu des entreprises pour placer
cette clientèle immigrante justement
sandrine tr avec vous on essaie de voir
ce qui se passe de l'autre côté de la
barrière
absolument c'est d'essayer de comprendre
effectivement les mécanismes du
recruteur pour pouvoir en tant que
candidat adapter son discours donc moi
je fais principalement de la formation
de recruteurs et l'immigration ce n'est
pas juste montréal et ses environs c'est
aussi au delà de montréal la région ça
c'est un peu votre domaine marie soleil
oui je réponds de l'organisme promis on
est situé dans côte-des-neiges on est un
organisme communautaire qui vise
l'intégration sociale et professionnelle
des personnes immigrantes et puis
effectivement il n'ya pas que montréal
donc on a est le programme de
régionalisation qui permet aux personnes
immigrantes qui souhaite quitter
montréal pour s'établir en région que ce
soit pour l'emploi pour entreprendre
pour un projet de vie je reviens vous
delphine faut lire comment est née
l'idée de ce salon
non c'est un salon qui est fait par des
immigrants pour des immigrants a dans
l'idée est l'aîné ya sept ans finalement
dans la tête de personnes qui venaient
de déposer ses valises ici au québec qui
aurait aimé trouver ce genre d'événement
et qui s'est dit pourquoi est ce que je
le ferai pas pour que ça serve à moi
même et aux autres alors l'idée c'est
vraiment de réunir sous un même toit
pendant deux jours une multitude de
services de programme d'organisation
d'opportunités qui ce qui s'adresse
spécifiquement aux nouveaux arrivants à
montréal en région c'est vraiment l'idée
c'est de mettre en lumière tous ceux qui
existent tout ce qui se fait pour que la
personne qui est fraîchement arrivé
puisse vraiment avoir tout sous la main
pendant deux jours on s'est parfois on
arrive à l'aéroport puis finalement on
sait qu'il ya une multitude de services
qui s'offrent à nous mais on sait pas
très bien où aller comment les
identifier et à chaque année au salon
moi ce qui me ce qui me comble en tant
qu'organisatrice c'est lorsque j'entends
les visiteurs qui ressorte en relisant
j'ai découvert des services je n'avais
même pas imaginer qu'ils existaient
alors je ne les aurai jamais chercher
parce que je ne savais pas que c'était
fait pour moi qu'il y avait des choses
comme ça pour moi que ce soit à montréal
ou dans d'autres régions
alors je crois que ça montre la
pertinence et l'utilité finalement de ce
genre d'initiative est ce vous avez
senti une espèce d'engouement qui a
progressé au fil des années depuis la
première édition jusqu'à l'édition
actuelle c'est sûr que je me rappelle la
première édition avec émotion encore
mais bien évidemment
le salon de l'immigration et
l'intégration au québec qu'on s'est fait
une place comme un événement récurrent
majeur qui permet évidemment d'informer
les nouveaux arrivants mais aussi c'est
une magnifique réunion je dirais de tous
les professionnels qui oeuvrent à
l'accueil à l'intégration des immigrants
il ya aussi beaucoup cet aspect
rencontre réseautage pour se découvrir
les uns et les autres
alors je dirais que d'année en année on
a de plus en plus d'organisations et de
partenaires majeurs qui s'associe au
salon parce que finalement s'ils ne sont
pas là que il manque profondément elles
sont parfois si monsieur adhikari
ouagadougou vous accompagnez les
migrants vous connaissez très bien peu
ce qu'ils ont comme problème quand votre
expérience votre perception que c'est
pas le plus gros défi auquel est
confronté le nouvel arrivant quand il
est là en matière de recherche d'emploi
si son plus grand défi le plus grand
défi c'est se définir
professionnellement en termes d'économie
et d'emploi au québec et au canada en
général
en d'autres termes c'est que ils
s'ignorent
dans le langage professionnel technique
ils se situent pas de point de vue
personnel et de points de vue
versus le marché de l'emploi
donc nous on a créé comme comme dans
l'est toujours en tout cas
un organisme visionnaire on a créé le
système de création de cv par grappes
qui fait l'objet de plusieurs ateliers
dans ce fameux salon à l'année à chaque
année et dans d'autres salons
spécialisés
il s'agit de démontrer le nouvel
arrivant dans tous ces profils
professionnels et ont tiré profit
d'autres se taire en d'autres termes
c'est de lui créer une multitude de cv
orienté ciblé par pause par occupation
par détail par compétences d'une façon
que il peut envoyer une centaine de cv
par jour tous les cv sont différents les
uns des autres et à des entreprises
différentes les unes des autres donc une
technologie de création de cv par
grappes pour qu' il puisse obtenir le
maximum possible d'entrevue ce qui amène
à mach 5 possibilités plus grand d'avoir
un emploi donc de façon exponentielle
plus du fait des entrevues gagnante le
spirent la chance d'obtenir un emploi
là la partie de ce que l'immigrant de
point de vue
milan des compétences il peut pas le
construire lui-même aussi en
terminologie et technique d'ici donc en
leurs habits il est toujours le même
mais on leur avis à chaque fois selon le
besoin de l'entreprise pas selon ses
exploits dans son pays d'origine
donc on va leur mettre dans une
situation qu est ce que tu peux faire à
l'entreprise parce que tu as fait aux
autres donc on va dans le profond volet
économique de rentabilité du cv donc le
cv qui va sentir l'argent et qui va
sentir aussi le facteur humain et le
facture facteur de productivité pour
qu'ils soient convaincants et aboutir à
un une entrevue et ensuite un emploi
c'est ça parce que là qu'ils sont c'est
à dire ceci peut-être monsieur carlier
parce que l'un des problèmes qu'on a
souvent c'est le problème de
l'expérience canadienne ou québécoise
pour un nouvel arrivant et dans un cv ou
ça manque parfois ça devient un obstacle
pour pour le nouvel arrivant
tout à fait et c'est pour ça que nous on
a développé notre projet de mentorat
donc le projet de mentorat c'est
justement faire un jumelage parce que
souvent le candidat le l'immigrant qui
est bien préparée avec les outils
justement pour aborder le marché du
travail
souvent ça demande c'est de rencontrer
d'être face à un employeur donc nous
dans ce cadre là on a développé le
mentorat le mentorat c'est justement un
jumelage avec des professionnels du
métier pour que cette personne puisse
mieux comprendre les rouages des
technicités québécoise dans sa
profession
donc on a une grande base de données de
mentor ce sont des bénévoles des
employeurs des personnes qui
travaillaient différents statuts dans
les entreprises voire même les
ressources humaines qui donnent de leur
temps pour accompagner rencontré ce
jeune immigrant et l'aider dans son
processus d'intégration professionnelle
donc ça c'est une passerelle que nous
avons bien développée à l'hirondelle est
toujours le but c'est de mettre en
relation ces immigrants avec les milieux
professionnels
parfois les migrants paient être mis en
contact avec le milieu professionnel
mais il sait pas vraiment comment ça
fonctionne et est là sandrine de tr
qu'elle
quelles sont souvent les attentes des
employeurs quels sont les combats cette
fonction du côté des employeurs des des
recruteurs par rapport à quelqu'un qui
en face de lui et lui ne s'est pas trop
nécessairement à ce qu'on attend de lui
mais qu'est ce que nous le chercheur
d'emploi d'emploi devrait savoir en fait
le maximum de choses avant d'aller au
stade du recruteur et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des organismes comme
l'hirondelle et puis comme la maisonnée
comme la maison et qui sont là et il
faut surtout pas hésiter à aller les
voir quand on est rendu à aller voir le
recruteur je parle du recruteurs en
entreprise
il faut être prêt le recruteur en
entreprise et je suis pas là pour
pleurer sur le sort des recruteurs loin
de là mais ils ont un facteur temps qui
est très important un recruteur en
entreprise en moyenne va recruter entre
20 et 25 postes
il va recevoir environ une centaine de
cv à peu près entre 50 et 100 cv
dépendamment des entreprises encore une
fois donc par poste donc il ya un
facteur temps derrière tout ça il faut
savoir que le recruteur il travaille pas
pour le candidat il travaille pour son
gestionnaire qui a un besoin il faut
qu'il réponde aux besoins de ce
gestionnaire là donc on essaye d'être le
plus empathique possible parce que c'est
quand même notre où l'on fait des
ressources humaines ont fait du
recrutement mais notre besoin vient du
gestionnaire et ne vient pas du candidat
donc quand le candidat arrive dans un
processus de sélection il doit être le
plus près possible parce que moi j'ai un
problème à résoudre
ils m'ont postes à combler et il faut
que la candidature qui arrivent soit le
plus proche possible du problème que
j'ai à résoudre finalement donc on est
on est assez réducteur monsieur carlier
parce que j'ai une petite parenthèse je
me souviens y avait un entreprise sinon
repris ce qu'avait dit pour moi le
candidat c'est mon aspirine qu'il faut
que je trouve ça alors donc c'est très
important de savoir comment bien s'en
douter il faudrait que le cv soit le
plus coller le plus proche possible de
la description
l'emploi ou des tâches qui sont
recherchés en fait oui je dois faire si
je reçois on va dire une cinquantaine de
cv par poste évidemment que dans un
premier temps je vais me diriger vers
les cv qui répondent le plus et qui sont
le plus en adéquation possible avec le
besoin que j'ai donc malheureusement ici
ça quelques fois qu'il difficile à
comprendre pour quelqu'un qui immigrent
qui dit mais pourquoi vous me donnez pas
ma chance c'est parce que moi mais j'ai
reçu peut-être sept huit autres cv de
personnes qui ont une expertise par
exemple ici et il est avec lesquels
c'est plus facile pour moi de valider et
c'est plus facile aussi pour mon
gestionnaire de le valider donc ces gens
là effectivement peuvent passer dans le
dos entre les mailles du filet et je
pense que ce qui est important quand
c'est ça parce que de trouver enfin
évidemment la fameuse première
expérience québécoise sous on en parle
mais s'ils décident de passer à travers
les mailles de ce filet là et de faire
notamment le plus possible on en parle
beaucoup mais de réseautage du mentorat
effectivement ça c'est ce qui va
permettre justement d'avoir un espèce de
passe-droit par rapport à juste la porte
d'entrée qui est le cv sur les bandes
qu'on décida les uns région est ce qu'on
est confronté aux mêmes types de
problèmes de défi ou bien c'est un peu
plus peu plus ouverts un peu moins ce
mois-ci eric qu'à montréal par exemple
la plupart des candidats qui viennent me
rencontrer en fait veulent contourner ce
problème là donc se retrouve à montréal
dans un marché plutôt saturé où ils ont
de la difficulté à retrouver le même
niveau de qualification qu'à l'origine
souvent ils ont passé par des emplois
des qualifiant aussi ce qui peut servir
d'expérience pour connaître le marché du
travail québécois
mais bref donc on essaie de contourner
ce par les emplois en région
donc la grande force du programme c'est
qu'on a des structures partout en région
donc des partenaires qui sont en lien
avec des employeurs qui sont intéressés
embaucher des personnes immigrantes et
puis donc c'est un réseau de référence
comme ça aussi de personnes de confiance
qui va amener donc la facilitation de l'
embauche des personnes migrantes en
région alem lagacé vont québec c'est pas
vraiment une région au sens comme on
parlerait pas du lac saint jean où la
côte nord mais quand même québec a aussi
ses besoins en matière d'immigration et
montréal qui se taille la part du lion
qu'est ce que vous faites vous pour
essayer d'attirer les gens chez vous non
il faut comprendre qu'effectivement on
est une région parce que la région
métropolitaine donc on est une région la
région métropolitaine de québec le fait
particulier à québec ce que le
taux d'emploi de nos migrants est quand
même très élevé on à 75,2 dans les 15 64
ce qui est très rare on est la seule
région au québec qui ont un taux
supérieur à 70%
notre population active croît beaucoup
moins rapidement que nos emplois donc on
est un dynamisme d'emploi extrêmement
élevé avec vous pouvez imaginer les
besoins que nous avons parce que même
dans la population immigrante
on ne retrouve pas qui est installé des
jeux chez nous on ne retrouve pas le
bassin de travailleurs
suffisant donc le meilleur moyen
d'attirer chez nous depuis dix ans c'est
ce qu'on fait c'est par l'emploi c'est
par la valorisation justement des
opportunités de carrière comme on fait
aujourd'hui au salon d'ailleurs donc
depuis dix ans c'est ce qu'on met de
l'avant et ça a été le critère principal
on a presque doublé le taux d'attraction
dans nombreux dans notre région depuis
environ les huit dernières années
mais on est quand même loin de la coupe
aux lèvres parce qu'on on attire
actuellement environ 7,2 pour cent des
immigrants sont un territoire est il
notre poids démographique quand même de
9,7 fiction - on est on tend vers le 9,7
pour au moins atteindre ce niveau là
mais on est très demandeur ou de gens
pour les attirer chez nous est le
facteur principal est bien sûr l'emploi
et c'est un facteur j'écoute beaucoup le
fait justement d'essayer d'amener les
gens de montréal vers les régions
c'est un facteur sur lequel on travaille
beaucoup on s'aperçoit par exemple avec
les années que c'est difficile aussi de
déraciner quelqu'un qui ait fait le
passage vers mots rien parce que là
souvent la seule chose qui leur réussit
c'est d'établir un peu son réseau et le
fait de le déraciner une deuxième fois
c'est souvent beaucoup plus difficile
pour une région d'attirer les gens
malgré le fait de l'emploi et le fait la
possibilité de la région québec sq on
s'aperçoit lorsqu on attire quelqu'un de
montréal c'est que là le travail en va
venir travailler chez nous mais la
famille ne déménagera pas souvent et ça
fait en sorte que l'employeur chez nous
a peut-être un peu difficultés à mettre
tous les efforts parce qu'il sait très
bien que comme une non engagement la
part de son travailleurs parce qu'il
fait les allers retours québec montréal
dont conduite est trop près de montréal
c'est elle la difficulté mais on doit
travailler fort pour faire en sorte que
la famille décide de poursuivre
l'aventuré avec le conjoint ou la
conjointe exactement donc pour
stabiliser un peu la situation du
travailleur c'est important qu'ils aient
cette notion familiales dues soit résolu
et vaud m mélissa pots de vin qu'est ce
que vous faites concrètement pour on va
des facilités ce regroupement familial
qu'est ce que vous faites mais en fait
c'est pas moi personne jeudi le cabinet
oui donc pris en main en fait cet
élément le passé comme vous le disiez la
famille c'est un élément qui est très
important donc quelqu'un qui arrive ici
au canada au québec et qui se retrouve
seul sans les membres de sa famille ça
peut être plus difficile de demeurer au
pays de demeurer au québec
sans cet élément le qui le rattache à
l'humain depuis donc c'est un élément
qui est important et le canada a pris en
compte
donc c'est juste vous donner un chiffre
en 2013 on
1 2296 mille résidents permanents qui
ont été à nous mais dans ce rôle-là 26%
et est issu du regroupement familial
alors c'est quand même une très bonne
portion et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement au fil des ans a tenté de
mettre de l'avant plan des politiques
qui dirait qui vise réellement à réunir
les familles donc nous c'est certain
qu'on fait beaucoup de choses mais entre
autres on vise à aider des gens à se
réunir ici au québec pour faciliter leur
intégration et leur volonté de demeurer
ici au canada ou à dix car vous parliez
de chaleur des bons civiles ulcérées par
rapport aux ventes
bon vous avez sûrement entendu parler
des histoires de personnes qui avec un
bon cv avec des bonnes compétences mais
qui s'appelle abd allah kouakou jean
baptiste guyenne ou sanchez ne sont pas
faussés par le processus ok oui est ce
qu est ce que vous avez quelle est votre
réflexion sur cet aspect des choses
je comprends bien l'étendue de votre
question et l'impact de ce qui a été
malheureusement médiatisé pour des cas
on peut dire l'art avec toute franchise
il y a eu des cas il y en a lyon nora
illi a partout 6 mondial dans mon pays
d'origine dont il y a toujours dans vos
restaurant le bifthèque moi je le veux
world and saignant me saignant etc
c'est pas bon c'est à dire comparé à ça
vous donne un exemple de ce qui est
arrivé c'est que les les les cas où il
ya eu discrimination ils sont vraies on
les nie pas ne s'est pas un phénomène et
ça ne pas être un obstacle à quelqu'un
doute est ce qu on dit aux gens en
recherche d'emploi qui vient d'arriver
au lieu dit combien vous croyez vous
avez des gens qui veulent pas votre
profil ou votre 5% 10% soit on travaille
avec les 90 % avec 4 80% avec les 60 %
donc mais tel effort dans ce qui est
positif
regardez les et les lélés les
institutions publiques la ville de
montréal les grandes villes regardez
l'enseignement regarder le sein de santé
et compter les migrants ils sont pas
donc il faut pas généraliser il y a eu
des cas rares mais il faut pas trop les
médiatiser de point de vue c'est une
leçon à prendre pour nous tous mais on
peut traiter les cas comme cas isolé
heureusement donc non on travaille avec
les nouveaux arrivants qui viennent avec
une bulle communautaire dont chacun avec
ses voisins dolisie du même origine ou
dans sa bulle communautaires ou de pays
d'origine et il est influencé à médecin
quand tu vas travail et l ingénieur
tu rêves qui va travailler est elle donc
ils viennent avec ces idées là ils sont
ils viennent d'être parachuté à montréal
puis ils sont comme on dirige confrontés
à ce type de de harcèlement et de 2,2
d'empoisonnement psychologique et
sociale donc en lice en fait les l'effet
contraire à ça et on les ouvre à toutes
les opportunités qu'il y a et puis les
exemples qu'il y a donc le cv qui
marchent pas actuellement avec la
situation du marché de l'emploi on est
on atteint presque le plein emploi au
québec là et c'est quelque chose donc
lisent les entreprises dans une bonne
économie dans une économie qui va bien
ils veulent faire davantage de l'argent
si l'argent il est dans telle communauté
hôtel personne de table rase de telles
croyances de telle origine on va le
prendre et ce qui se passe depuis
maintenant plus de deux ans l'a donc le
phénomène dont vous parlez que à cause
de mon originaux de mes croyances ou
deux mais de ma culture d'origine
c'est un phénomène qui est très minime
actuellement et heureusement
et ça va durer parce que l'employeur
québécois vente en tirer le sent aussi
qu'il va voir les perles qui ce qui qui
viennent dans son entreprise il va en
prendre d'avantagé en demander davantage
là où il y aura peut-être des moments
plus difficiles
plus tard je met les autres personnes
réagissent à ça c'est à dire l'idée que
bon avec le plein emploi
le discours qu'on soit entendu par ceux
qui sont réfractaires voire hostile à
l'immigration que ces discours peuvent
s'estomper
parce que là clairement même pour ceux
qui étaient sceptiques on se rend compte
qu'on a vraiment besoin de main d'oeuvre
oui on se rend compte qu'on a
effectivement besoin de la main d'oeuvre
immigrante par contre je crois pas que
ce soit
roman c'est le fait de dire que les
personnes immigrantes ont des
limitations à l'emploi sont victimes
d'une certaine discrimination de
certains employeurs donc on travaille
beaucoup aussi à la sensibilisation des
communautés par exemple pour notre part
en région et des employeurs aussi en
région donc ne pas faire semblant que
les personnes immigrantes sont
exactement les mêmes que nous connaître
leurs différences savoir comment les
accueillir et que tout le monde y
contribuer parce que sinon ça fait des
projets qui ne perdure pas puis qui sont
des échecs assez cuisant donc une
personne par exemple qu'il irait en
région qui arrivent pas s'intégrer puis
qu'il doit revenir à montréal donc on on
s'assure que le terrain soit fertile à
ça donc je crois que oui il ya des
limitations mais il ya des moyens à
prendre aussi la sensibilisation
et puis donc des politiques dans les
entreprises des mesures dans les
communautés aussi avoue delphine mc la
même chose c'est-à-dire le contexte
actuel qui favorise qui est de plus en
plus favorables en faite aux migrants ou
gens qui parfois avec des difficultés à
intégrer le marché du travail
oui en fait moi je peux témoigner par
exemple pour le salon d'une migration
il ya sept ans quand on a lancé le salon
on a sept entreprises qui étaient
présentes pour recruter des candidats
immigrants aujourd'hui à cette septième
édition on a cinquante entreprises qui
sont présentes soit pendant les deux
jours soit sur des créneaux de
recrutement express
on a particulièrement cette année des
entreprises qui sont en région les
entreprises de la ville de québec et de
ses environs notamment qui sont qui sont
très représentés cette année
et moi je pense aussi qu'il ya certaines
entreprises qui n'ont plus le choix et
qu'ils ont compris depuis quelques
années aussi parce qu'elles n'ont plus
le choix que de se tourner vers ce qu'on
dit le talent international de regarder
aussi cette possibilité pour combler
leur équipe parce que sinon ça peut
signifier tout simplement ne pas pouvoir
prendre un mandat à prendre un contrat
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la main d'oeuvre
pour ensuite livrer le produit fini ou
la fin de la marchandise alors
évidemment c'est extrêmement
handicapants pour le développement
économique de ces entreprises est de
l'agglomération de la région dans
laquelle dans laquelle ils sont donc je
crois qu'on voit quand même se dessiner
des changements depuis depuis quelques
années mais c'est définitivement qui a
encore du travail à faire du chemin à
faire aussi de la part d'entreprises qui
sont peut-être moins habitués à la
diversité qui ont besoin de comprendre
qu'est-ce que c'est un candidat
immigrants d'où il vient
quelles sont ses compétences comment est
ce qu'on peut lire ces qualifications
il ya assez sûrs d'eux du du parcours
mais j'ose espérer en tout cas moi je
suis optimiste mais qu' on est on est
sur des bons rails aussi est de toute
façon le développement économique et le
développement de manière plus générale
du québec et du canada passera en partie
par l'immigration
madame lagos et oui mais je peux
témoigner parce que la région de québec
ça fait de ce fait plus de dix ans
maintenant qu'on est en plein emploi et
l'effet que ça fait c'est effectivement
ça va ouvrir les esprits le besoin
lillois donc ça peut être très
rapidement l'employant va avoir un peu
l'effet de survie de dire donc de
s'ouvrir rapidement al embauche ce qu'il
faut faire attention par exemple c'est
qu'il ya une ouverture à l'embauché mais
il faut justement pas prendre pour
acquis
c'est l'effet appelé et qu'il faut faire
une attention particulière c'est
effectivement de sensibiliser beaucoup
plus l'employant sur la gestion de la
diversité
cette diversité la gestion des conflits
dans un contexte justement multipoint de
faire attention aussi aux ressources
qu'ils y étaient des jo qui comprennent
très bien qu'on va chercher des gens
pour combler parce que l'on est en train
de refuser des contrôles ne tenterai
même de penser de se délocaliser
mais dans la vie de tous les jours par
exemple les impacts puces peuvent
arriver très rapidement donc le travail
qu'on doit vraiment faire et ne pas
prendre pour acquis que même si on est
ouvert à l' embauche comme c'est par la
suite qu'il faut accompagner vraiment de
proximité les entreprises parce que
effectivement il y aura un peu le ressac
tout ça par la suite va venir il faut
bien armer l'entreprise et la communauté
d'accueil pour bien gérer toute cette
dimension là mais effectivement ça l'a
en effet de survie l'entrepreneur quand
ça fait mal il va s'ouvrir très
rapidement il vaut agir
et s'il faut qu'elle cherchait des gens
à l'international ses focales cherchait
déjà à ja et voltaire c'est après qu'il
faut faire une attention particulière
sur les carriers que les lots rôle d'un
conseiller
on va dire un partenariat entreprise
comme vous qu'est ce que vous faites
exactement justement c'est de travailler
sur les deux volets autant auprès des
entreprises parce que comme on vient de
le citer les entreprises il faut aussi
les accompagner
on pense que des fois l'entreprise elle
peut engager puis s'est ou non il faut
aussi les encadrer les accompagner donc
on va les soutenir dans ce que ce soit
la gestion de la diversité et
l'intégration professionnelle en milieu
professionnel et on a bien sûr aussi un
travail auprès de la clientèle sur toute
la culture organisationnelle comment
s'organiser comment se préparer quel et
l'environnement de travail est ce qui va
avoir un encadrement d'accueil de
formation
tout ça est important donc moi dans mon
rôle de partenariat de d'entreprise
c'est justement de valider de soutenir
les entreprises en soute dans ses
différents volets et en interne l'équipe
de conseillers en emploi travaillent
justement auprès de la clientèle donc
c'est un travail qui se fait en en
commun tant auprès des milieux des
entreprises que des de la clientèle
immigrante célèbre jeu revient à vous
alors limiter l'immigration à région et
là on va dire de plus en plus c'est une
option qui est de plus en plus explorées
mais on sait aussi que parfois on a un
problème de rétention est ce que le
problème se pose plus si vous compariez
passant par montréal pour l'un des
rétentions de mobilité des gens qui
viennent et finalement qu'il décide de
repartir parce qu'ils sont déçus
est ce que c'est un problème que vous
vous constatez oui un problème
au niveau du maintien donc c'est pour ça
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure de la
sensibilisation aussi de l'aspect de la
présence du conjoint de la famille et
donc du conjoint qui ont un emploi de la
famille qui est un projet qui est un
réseau social
donc ça aide à contrer justement ce
problème là de 2,2 et que les gens ces
tables et ceux qui vont revenir à
montréal ou à aller ailleurs aussi donc
effectivement le ccc un 10/10 voilées
qu'on continue à travailler
voilà je sais pas si c'est un peu mieux
vous en pris connaissance des grandes
lignes de la nouvelle politique du
québec nous sommes ensemble nous sommes
le québec qui est une solution aux
problèmes de main d'oeuvre actuelle je
pose la question de façon générale est
ce quelqu'un a une idée en commentaire à
faire sur cette politique là sur les
effets possibles de cette politique sur
le problème qui a un problème on
constate qu'ils celui de la main
d'oeuvre tout à l'heure les intervenants
qui vont donner des cas concrets de
problèmes de main d'oeuvre
est-ce que vous avez des commentaires
sur cette politique à 8 madame de
l'agaci quand on regarde la politique on
comprend qu 1,3 million de postes on est
à pourvoir et 80% de ces postes-là vont
être en région ce à dire or la grande
région de montréal et je pense qu'il
faut vraiment faire une attention
particulière parce que on a beau puis ça
revient mon commentaire de tout talent
c'est qu'on n'a pas supporté les
initiatives d'attraction des régions à
partir du moment où on ne supporte pas
l'écosystème pour justement permettre
une intégration réussie de la famille
est tout sauf ça il faut les accompagner
pour accompagner la prise en charge des
régions et l'on se retrouve très
rapidement avec peu de personnes dédiées
à ce volet là et ça peut rapidement être
difficile donc il faut absolument que
dans la politique gouvernementale
on continue les appuis d'attraction de
l'international vers les régions je le
mentionnais tantôt c'est beaucoup plus
facile d'attirer et on on sait que
l'individu fait le choix de venir chez
nous donc c'est beaucoup plus facile de
l'attirer de l'international directement
chez nous et de supporter les écoles cem
régionaux
pour une intégration réussie parce que
cette expertise là d'intégrale
d'installation d'intégration
d'accompagnement à l'emploi
d'intégration globale n'existe pas en
région
et ça il faut supporter les écosystèmes
pour permettre justement ce chrono oui à
la retraite
les mystères de l'immigration de la
diversité de l'inclusion le vient de
de mettre sur pied un projet spécial
donc de ré ouvrir des antennes en
régions puis donc ça risque
il risque d'avoir plus de souci à ce
niveau-là donc les prochaines années
alors quand je reviens maintenant à vous
mélissa pots de vin parlant du
parrainage et du regroupement familial
est ce qu'au fond en matière de
parrainage c'est de l'argent qui le nerf
de la guerre
si j'ai plus de monde aux ressources
financières je peux facilement ramener
ma famille ici où ce n'est pas sans
impact et parmi tant d'autres
non en fait ce qui est bien avec le
regroupement familial
ces guerres on peut donc
justement parrainer un membre de notre
famille pour kilian dit la vérité au
québec au canada à titre de résident
permanent
et puis dépendamment du lien de famille
qui existe entre deux personnes c'est ce
qui peut déterminer si on doit démontrer
aux feuilles finances qui on doit
démontrer notre capacité financière puis
prenez vos besoins et demandes de notre
famille et mais lorsqu'on parle d'un
disque ou conjointe du fait d'un enfant
à charge
on ne peut pas à démontrer cette
capacité financière alors c'est vraiment
un bon élément parce que ils sont
effectivement ça peut être si ça peut
être difficile de démontrer cette
capacité là toutefois il faut démontrer
notre intention de subvenir aux besoins
d'une famille donc lorsqu'on parienne
quelqu'un on va devoir s'engager avec le
gouvernement pour prendre prendre
l'initiative de faciliter l'intégration
d'une demande de notre famille
et advenant le cas où il devrait avoir
recours à des de l'aide sociale du
gouvernement
alors on s'engage à rembourser ces
sommes
non faut quand même est prêt à investir
de l'énergie et du temps de l'argent
advenant le cas où la personne est en
besoin de deux soucis donc il faut cet
élément-là d'aspe financier est présent
mais pour qu'une personne immigrée elle
n'a pas besoin nécessairement de
démontrer son seuil financier à une
certaine hauteur pour pouvoir parrainer
salomon 9 sa famille c'est vrai
toutefois dans le cas des parents grands
parents
donc si jamais on veut parrainer
ses membres les membres de cette famille
de la famille en tant que parents grands
parents
il va falloir démontrer notre seuil
financier mais autrement c'est vraiment
le critère de sélection c'est le lien
qui existe entre les familles donc ce
sera un très bon élément est pour
regrouper les familles ce week end
mais est ce qu'on peut se passer de vous
des avocats dans ce processus là ben non
elle dit le contraire et c'est presque
un peu c'est un peu bête mais non
effectivement c'est bien aussi d'avoir
ainsi par des avocats pour justement
avoir une bonne compréhension du
processus et des responsabilités aux des
obligations qui découlent du processus
de parrainage d'une part et du nom donc
il ya des obligations et des
responsables des temps pour la personne
qui parraine et pour la personne qui est
pas réunie donc c'est bon d'avoir une
bonne idée d'ensemble de ce en quoi ça
consiste pour être bien renseigné et
pour pouvoir ensuite que le processus se
fasse de façon vraiment doué que tout le
monde soit au courant un des aspects du
parrainage mais non donc on est là pour
vraiment accompagner les familles et
s'assurer que leur dossier est complet
au moment du dépôt puis qui est pas
d'embûches
on essaie vraiment de prévoir toutes les
anomalies questions de santé de sécurité
donc oui on est là pour les accompagner
à une autre question générale le taux de
chômage est globalement bas au québec
mais en même temps on sait que dans les
communautés culturelles
il est beaucoup plus élevée que dans la
moyenne nationale on cherche des gens à
l'étranger pour combler des postes ici
alors qu'il ya des gens ici qui n'ont
pas d'emploi
qu'est ce qui se passe pour qu'on ait ce
soit en fixant des situations oui
monsieur
car donc il y a eu quelques grandes
entreprises qui ont eu
l'initiative d'aller chercher des
travailleurs dans les îles maurice
madagascar installés dans d'autres
endroits en europe aussi en europe de
l'est
80 % ont échoué dans leurs opérations
dans le processus parce que il se
trouvait que les profils qu'ils
cherchent c'est une chose puisqu'il est
à la basse et des gens qui cherchent des
emplois vrai de haut niveau et bien
rémunéré donc c'est pas une n'ont pas
trouvé le bassin de main-d'oeuvre
général de production dans ces endroits
là donc c'était une une erreur de
logistique c'est leur parole là je ne
vous raconte pas la mienne là donc c'est
une erreur logistique
puis ils nous ont révélé que cette
énergie donc ils sont retournés à à la
berge donc chercher ici à montréal et
partout au québec des immigrants pour
leurs besoins dans le lait puis ce sont
des entreprises en région en général
donc nous en fait à chaque année dans
sept dans cet objectif là des opérations
de speedo bingde d'entrevue éclair
majeur en fait trois quatre fois par
année pour à peu près sur l'année 600
personnes pour les placements et 80%
c'est pour les régions donc fruit de
ceux de ce très beau salon donc d'onde
en ont au moins de deux semaines
on va faire un spi jogging de
d'envergure pour le placement en emploi
des gens qui sont ici aujourd'hui et
demain pour le plasma l'emploi dans les
régions du québec
donc capitale nationale ottawa estrie a
pas l'âge
côte-nord partout donc mais on s'est
focalisé cette fois sur le placement
l'emploi dans la région de deux bosses
donc pour puis à chaque à chaque deux
trois mois un fait un ski joring pour à
peu près 180 200 personnes pour le
placement en emploi de ce genre et en
prend les immigrants les résidants
permanents les réfugiés et les
demandeurs d'asile donc tout strate des
migrations confondues à bien vous avez
un point de vue sur la question sandrine
pierre sur ce paradoxe là entre oui m on
a besoin de gens va à l'étranger alors
qu'ici à des gens qui cherchent à
trouver un emploi
en fait effectivement on vient gros
paradoxe est plus près ce que je dirais
une inadéquation au niveau du marché
mais je pense qu'il faut que oui on est
sur deux marchés complètement différent
et on est sur des spécificités très
différente aussi pourquoi est-ce qu'on
va à l'étranger recruter aujourd'hui je
discutais justement avec une entreprise
de québec qui recrutent beaucoup à
l'international présentement parce
qu'elle ne trouve pas ses compétences là
ici donc c'est vraiment par rapport à
une rareté de main-d'oeuvre dans un
secteur d'activité spécifique donc on
peut pas généraliser je pense par
rapport à ça on l'a trouvé une époque
pour des soudeurs on lance moment pour
des pauses de mécanicien on l'a beaucoup
évidemment dans le domaine des
technologies de l'information mais pas
dans d'autres
donc je pense juste qu'il faut rajouter
à ça oui mais dans quel secteur
d'activité
est ce qu'une solution possible compte
tenu du fait qu'on a justement des gens
qui sont là qui cherchent un emploi qu
est-ce qu on peut suggérer mais des
experts dans le domaine
est-ce que vous avez des idées là-dessus
et en fait moi je dirais c'est sûr que
le marché évolue énormément les
entreprises sont dans les docks les
technologies il faut comprendre il faut
pas remettre non plus en question le
ministère d'une migration qui fait son
travail de sélection à l'étranger puis
d'acceptation la seule chose qu'on sait
déjà il ya un décalage entre le moment
où la personne fait sa demande à
l'étranger pour immigrés puis le moment
où elle va arriver sur le territoire le
marché a déjà changé c'est sûr et
certain et l'autre élément c'est sûr que
les solutions mais on les ans il ya des
cégeps qui offre des désaxés des
formations d'appoint
il ya la reconnaissance des acquis
souvent les gens les la clientèle
immigrante ne naît pas au courant de ses
moyens qui leur permet d'accéder
rapidement aux connaissances techniques
de certains métiers de certaines
spécificités et c'est un peu le rôle des
organismes justement et des conseillers
en emploi d'accompagner de présenter ses
différents services pour des mises à
jour de connaissances spécifiques très
bien oui madame lagarde
je pense qu'on attend tous impatiemment
aussi que le ministère de l'immigration
met en place son nouveau programme
d'immigration basée sur la déclaration
d'intérêt donc la déclaration d'intérêts
c'est vraiment de former un bassin de
candidats potentiels qui manifeste son
intérêt à venir travailler ici au québec
et l'employeur donc un offre d'emploi
pour à piger dans ce bassin là
l'individu qui correspond davantage à
son profil
et là on va essayer d'accélérer
justement le pour le traitement du
dossier d'immigration de l'individu donc
plus on va se rapprocher de cette
adéquation la plus justement en europe
parce que ce qu'on avait vécu ce qui est
qui beaucoup vécu entre autres dans la
région de montréal c'est l'acceptation
de bassins selon une certaine grille de
sélection qui faisait en sorte que
l'individu dont le dossier était traité
en fonction de la date d'arrivée de son
dossier et le temps passe à l'individu
qui arrive ne correspondait peut-être
pas nécessairement au besoin on
n'atteignait pas la l'adéquation
recherché avec l'emploi donc le nouveau
système d'immigration entre de notre
côté on pop beaucoup d'espoir au fait
que l'on réussisse à atteindre une
certaine une meilleure adéquation et une
rapidité d'action dans le processus
d'immigration
il faut comprendre je pense aussi que
pour certains secteurs d'activité et
certaines métier aux professions ils
sont extrêmement recherchés parfois dans
le monde
donc finalement je dirais que le québec
le canada montréal québec etc sont en
compétition avec des métropoles du monde
entier et il faut vraiment être agile
dans la façon de pouvoir repérer des
talents et de les amener dans les
entreprises si au niveau de la procédure
c'est trop longue
le candidat finalement va peut-être être
tenté d'aller ailleurs dans le monde
dans un cadre quand même actuel de
mobilité internationale assez ses
profondes
alors je pense que c'est vraiment des
choses aussi qui probablement sont en
train de cogiter dans les têtes
malgré vous faites un peu du lobbying
pour le québec avec à travers immigrants
québec avec tout ce que vous offrez
quand l'information est ce que vous avez
un soutien direct ou indirect des
autorités qui liront connaissent
l'importance de ce que vous faites c'est
sûr que nous on croit on croit fermement
que le québec est une belle terre
d'opportunités pour une vie
professionnelle une vie familiale une
terre d'épanouissement
donc on aider on est des convaincus du
du québec pour être tous immigrants dans
l'équipe d'immigrants québec
et évidemment on reçoit l'encouragement
le soutien mais je dirais en fait des
180 exposants qui sont aujourd'hui
présents au salon de l'immigration et de
tous nos grands partenaires qui nous
accompagnent depuis depuis des années et
qui rendent possible en fait tout
simplement le salon l'immigrant québec
est un organisme à but non lucratif
indépendant est autofinancé donc
bénéficions d'aucune subvention publique
mais par contre c'est la présence comme
je le disais de nos grands partenaires
et des heures et des exposants qui rend
tout simplement ce grand événement
annuel depuis sept ans possible baril
sous les bombes
est ce que un région et il y à des
besoins qui sont plus plus importants
que d'autres et qui font aussi à des
demandes qui sont beaucoup plus
pressante
compte tenu du fait que bon il ya il ya
des besoins de façon générale mais il y
en a qui sont bouclés des besoins sont
beaucoup plus présents pour vous dans le
domaine de la santé donc
les préposés aux bénéficiaires
infirmiers infirmiers auxiliaires
médecin donc et techniciens de
laboratoire de l'ag aussi dans kane
grande demande à peu près partout en
région pour ça donc ça peut être une
belle solution justement pour un marché
de l'emploi montréal qui est compétitif
donc souvent les gens ont travaillé
davantage au privé à montréal donc le
yacht oublier les sinus c3 asus eee qui
sont intéressés à voir ses candidats en
santé entre autres
voilà sans doute d'ailleurs on a abordé
un petit peu le point de vue des
recruteurs mais est ce qu'il ya des
choses qu'on n'a pas dit qui sert
importante que leur le chercheur
d'emploi nouvel arrivant ou immigrants
sache dans la psychologie ou dans la
manière de penser
ddd recruteur vous avez deux heures oui
par où commencer en fait le conseil en
fait peut-être aujourd'hui cessé de dire
que tout est accessible au niveau des
informations pour quelqu'un qui
immigrent moi j'ai immigré moi même il
ya 25 ans pis on avait rien là il n'y
avait même pas de salon des migrations
où étais-tu delphine mais aujourd'hui
tout est accessible tout est en ligne et
l'information est aussi quand même
majoritairement gratuite
les réseaux sociaux allez voir les
profils des entreprises
soyez curieux intéressés vous les
profils des recruteurs sont aussi en
ligne aujourd'hui donc vous pouvez avoir
accès à leur profil
donc je dirais plus vers la curiosité et
vers l'accessibilité à toute
l'information qui est là on le voit au
salon je dire tous les organismes qui
sont là pour soutenir l'immigration donc
c'est de profiter de tout ça pour
pouvoir être le plus près possible
finalement quand on arrive je reviens ce
que je disais tout à l'heure mais quand
on arrive aux recruteurs madame lagacé a
abordé la question de du changement qui
est en train de s'opérer
parce qu'au fond ce qu'on a remarqué
c'est que les gens sont recrutés sont à
l'étranger sont sélectionnés sur la base
d'une éducation des diplômes et ils
arrivent ici ils ont l'impression que le
diplôme ne sont plus vertes
nous sommes plus intéressant pour vos
repartir à zéro faut changer de changer
d'orientation
je sais pas ce que vous vous en pensez
vous pensez de cette problématique là
qui est souvent source de déception pour
certaines personnes qui frappa façon
biais de quitter le québec
ils en veulent au processus en veulent à
presque tout le monde parce que les
choses ne sont pas passées comme on a
respiré
ils pensaient que leur diplôme était un
critère important pour leur arrivée au
québec au canada et finalement le
diplôme en question n'est pas n'est pas
reconnu sauf que les entreprises ne
travaille pas avec des diplômes en
général historique des compétences et la
difficulté moi je pensais que le
l'immigrant général mais il a une
difficulté de ceux de se mettre en
valeur
s'cusez moi je prends toujours
l'expression de se vendre parce qu'on y
soit marché il faut se vendre et c'est
sûr que souvent culturellement c'est pas
dans nos habitudes de ce vent parce que
dans notre pays justement notre diplôme
et avait une valeur ajoutée exacte est
on se présentait avec le diplôme ici je
pense oui dans certaines entreprises les
diplômes sont importants par rapport à
certains postes
mais beaucoup les compétences que
l'entreprise veut le découvrir veut
entendre de la personne et c'est là
qu'on va confronter un peu la difficulté
de l'immigrant ces deux excusés encore
l'expression suivante voilà concrètement
comment comment peut-on se vendre
comment doit-on se vendent bien en fait
bon je travaille un petit peu dans le
domaine notamment pharmaceutiques qui
ont ça va souvent arrivé par exemple que
quelqu'un pose sa candidature pour un
poste de technicien alors qu'il est un
doctorat et là il me dit qu'est ce que
je fais avec mon pied gauche dit il ça
arrive très très très fréquemment il ya
aussi problèmes de lag de l'as de la
sueur diplomation dans certains rites
pratiqués effectivement énormément de
frustration donc on se retrouve avec des
gens qui sont très frustrés après encore
une fois je pense qu'il ya toute une
réflexion à faire de part la personne
immigrante de voir mike son cheminement
qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire ici
jusqu'où est ce qu'elle est prête
éventuellement aller mais il met encore
une fois c'est une méconnaissance du
marché
cette frustration là et a mené par une
méconnaissance finalement si la personne
se préparent davantage et à une
ouverture d'esprit effectivement à ce
qu'on attend d'elle on diminuera
probablement un petit peu ce facteur
frustration
très bien alors une question que je
l'abordé avec une prochaine invitée mais
va falloir qu'on lui cède la place parce
qu'on a un problème de place en ce
moment on va on a mélissa qui est prête
à céder sa place c'est gentil c'est très
apprécié donc on va voir madame karine
jolicoeur des relevés qui est directrice
de la clinique juridique profil elle va
elle va prendre place d'un moment à
l'autre
voilà alors parce que elle elle a quand
même une spécialité c'est qu'elle
s'intéresse entre autres choses des
épreuves l'intégration des
professionnels tant qu'ils ont un
diplôme qu'une formation d'ailleurs et
faut intégrer nos professionnels
canadiens québécois c'est pas toujours
facile
donc c'est encore des ingénieurs qui se
retrouvent chauffeur de taxi et ainsi de
suite
madame donc bonjour un champ messieurs
bonjour alors qu'est-ce qui se passe est
ce qu'on ne fait pas confiance aux
formations au parcours d'ailleurs pour
qu'on arrive ici venant de france avait
des diplômes et des diplômes français
pour ne pas pouvoir intégrer un ordre
professionnel québécois qu'est-ce qui se
passe ah non je pense que c'est pas une
forme à une question de confiance mais
une question de connaissances et
d'informations temps pour l'immigrant
professionnels qui arrivent ici
qui a besoin de démystifier le système
professionnel et je parle au niveau
culturel le corps la façon d'exercer une
profession réglementée diffère des pays
donc la façon dont on exerce le métier
d'avocat en europe est différent de la
façon dont on exerce ce métier d'avocat
ici au québec en amérique du nord et je
suis bien placé pour en parler puisque
c'est mon métier d'origine
et quand je suis arrivé ici j'ai dû
repasser des examens d'équivalence pour
porter le titre d'avocate au québec
néanmoins ya un enjeu énorme qui est
pour l'immigrant de comprendre comment
on exerce une profession pour les
médecins ça serait plutôt parler de
protocole quel protocole appliqué pour
les infirmières est également mais il ya
tout un enjeu de compréhension de la
culture professionnelle et bout de ce
que je vois la clinique juridique c'est
souvent le noeud
qui contribuent à des incompréhensions
et à des blocages de part et d'autre
mais je crois que on ne peut pas parler
de manque de confiance ou de méfiance je
ne pense pas que cela soit adéquat selon
pas du corporatisme
est-ce que fasse aussi de mauvaise
perception de la chose qu'on parle du
corporatisme
c'est un groupe les avocats les médecins
issus de suite
encore une fois je pense que ce sont des
mots qui ont beaucoup de sens et qui
sont forts mais qui ne sont pas adaptés
parce que derrière c'est derrière cette
impression là il ya une incompréhension
de part et d'autre et un besoin
d'information c'est pour ça que nous
avons mis en place la clinique juridique
profils au sein de la faculté de droit
de l'université de montréal c'est pour
apporter une information
oui et permettre aux professionnels et
une grande cheminée face aux différents
acteurs locaux donc ça peut être l'ordre
ça peut être un maître de stage ça peut
être voilà donc le plus gros obstacle si
je suis juré du veau de propos c'est
vraiment d'ordre culturel donc de
l'incompréhension will à
l'incompréhension de la réglementation
locale de la façon d'exercer une
profession oui je pense que c'est un
enjeu énorme au point de départ parce
que les métiers ne sont les professions
ne sont pas exercer la même façon selon
la même culture d'un pays à l'autre
voilà monsieur karam sur ce sujet oui je
voudrais d'abord je me sers madame la
clinique juridique de ces de montréal
fait un grand travail à ce propos puis
elle a même pris la relève de d'un rôle
qu'avait le conseil interprofessionnel
bon pour la question de
deux des autres professionnels des
métiers réglementés ou des métiers régis
par des lois
moi je vais aller plus loin que
l'ignorance ou méconnaissance
moi j'irais même pour une volonté de ne
pas connaître
malheureusement parce que l'éducation
est mondialisée le savoir est
mondialisée il y a plus de secret
l'université d'abidjan ou de port au
prince où de gros trous dedans car à
odos d'alger on sait qu est-ce qu il
donne comme com renseignements comme
niveaux d'enseignement le niveau de la
technologie
le chirurgien qui a fait dix ans dans
tel pays et qui vient ici il n'est pas
reconnu
l'infirmière également retourner faire
toutes inscriptions universitaires deux
fois à partir de zéro le système
juridique oui c'est une exception parce
que le le le droit de la po lyon c'est
pas comme le droit de la reine donc le
problème c'est au ces que les ordres
professionnels et les gens responsables
dans les comités sectoriels et les
comités paritaires et dans les
indispensables pour les comités pour
l'ailé les métiers réglementés
la commission de la construction tu peux
devenir ministre avant que tu puisse
trouver un emploi en construction et va
la commission de la construction dit que
tu as dix ans d'expérience en est restée
de construction ou en plomberie qui
regardent le
le retour de battue va revenir à l'école
des métiers de la notion du québec tu
vas faire un dieu paix tu vas voir la
reconnaissance des acquis c'est une
chose mais la non volonté d'ouverture
des autres professionnels vous vous avez
bien dit que 1 20 docteurs a travaillé
comme chauffeur de taxi malheureusement
c'est que le le collège des médecins
devaient encore faire beaucoup plus le
lord est un des architectes l'ordre des
ingénieurs a fait beaucoup d'efforts
l'ordre des chimistes a fait énormément
d'efforts c'est ouvert mais
malheureusement il yad'autres d'autres
organismes qui sont cloîtrés de
protectionnisme si on veut c'est ainsi
c'est trop dire mais le résultat c'est
sans les juger par les résultats
malheureusement et il faut une ouverture
de la part de ses instances la alors
madame joly car développer quant à des
situations litigieuses vous êtes quand
même aux côtés des d'aider des gens que
vous vous accompagner pour les aider à
nous leur donnons l'information
juridique relative aux procédures
possibles aux plaintes possible et au
droit à leurs droits
alors avant de nous quitter parce que
malheureusement le temps passe très vite
on n'a plus un sujet qu'on aurait pu
aborder et là sont un problème de temps
et qu'il faut qu'il faut respecter
est ce que il pas mieux ya quelqu'un
d'autre qui voudraient ajouter un mas
chose particulière dans son dans son
domaine des choses qu'on n'a pas les
stocks on n'a pas abordé
marie soleil on a toute autorité fait
sandrine tr comme je disais si vous avez
deux heures on peut continuer
ledit carrier moi je dirais c'est sûr
que surtout ici face à nous nous avons
justement des immigrants qui sont là qui
sont en démarche de recherche d'emploi
quand je disais je leur dirai le message
mais c'est sûr qu'il faut persévérer à
la recherche d'emploi c'est pas une
facilité armez vous de patience parce
que ça c'est le facteur qui souvent
contre eux contre nous dans la démarche
de recherche d'emploi mais informe et
vous allez voir les bonnes personnes
poser vos bonnes questions c'est sûr et
certain pour avoir vos bonnes réponses
et pour vous permettre d'avancer
d'autant mieux dans votre démarche et je
pense qu'ici autour de la table on a
justement une belle brochette de
personnes qui sont immigrantes jeu j'en
suis moi même et la preuve c'est qu'on
peut réussir est content quand on aura
réussi on sera bien ici au québec c'est
sûr et certain
voilà vous pouvez continuer a justement
parlé avec nous nous inviter après après
l'émission
je remercie notre hôte delphine folliet
grâce à qui on est tous là et tous les
autres invités qui ont eu la gentillesse
de venir ici
merci à vous d'être là merci à ceux qui
nous écoutent en direct sur différentes
plateformes
versez y est très heureuse vous avoir eu
aujourd'hui et on sait déjà bientôt
merci
[Applaudissements]